It's just me.
I need a power. I'll take you one day to touch and then jump on it.
Yeah, I have a power.
I have a power. Won't stop me again tonight.
LA, LA, LA, LA,
LA, LA.
That's what I get in love.
I'll be showing up to break that night.
I'm real soft. I have a power.
I'll take you one day to touch and then tell me what it is.
It's my love, baby.
But I know who I'm a power,
not a father. The bonkers tell me you can be nice.
LA, LA, LA,
LA, LA, LA.
What you think about me,
what you think about me, what you think about me,
what you think about me.
Just trust me. I'm a coward.
If you're wondering what's in it,
tell me what it means. Stand up, baby.
Words are who I am. I'm a coward.
I'm a Fowler. Won't stop me. Can't deny.
Daddy, daddy,
daddy, daddy, daddy.
You're a woman. No, man.
I wanna cause I might.
Ah.